joining us first outside the arena in
Orlando sorry we got to put down the
Rolling Stones there is Fox News
contributor the guy that we love my
friend by the way so I made an audible
Lawrence and the audible was you were
supposed to be in California you had
this horrible experience that you talked
about yesterday right on this program
and I'm still angry about it so I said
no I want Lawrence to go down to Orlando
and I want him to meet other people not
at the impeach Trump rally what's the
difference Lawrence Sun look at all of
these people right here today they are
excited about the president what he
delivered on I got some new friends here
first I got Susan right here Susan tell
our audience a Sean what you feel like
is the number one accomplishment of this
president this president has kept his
promises to the people of the United
States whether it's popular or not he
keeps his promise he has more energy and
that place was explosive tonight full of
enthusiasm and the man is like the
Eveready Bunny he just keeps on going
god bless Donald Trump Sean you hearing
it from yourself people here that are
electric they feel like the president
delivered on his promise I got my
brother Mike here where's my kid
come here Mike Mike this this is a guy
from my community how do you feel like
the president has delivered on issues
when it comes to black America man
honestly as a black American I have
never seen a president do so much for
our community as this president you're
talking about Louis unemployment you got
prison reform first step act urban
revitalization this president is
delivering on his promises and he's
unifying the country on top of that you
know over on the Left I had an
opportunity to go and see the anti-trump
protesting and it was all just
negativity the energy in this room was
electric and positive you know
conservatives call me Patriot American
brother leftist they call me other
things that I will not say on TV but as
a
Americans we are united under this
president Sean back to you in New York
you're hearing it from yourself from the
Pacers here right here at my Sunnah
Lawrence I got a question for you I know
it's hard to hear so we become good
friends we've become good friends and
you don't have to admit that publicly
but do you like the audible I called you
got to be honest I like audible that you
call I mean these people have been
showing me love all day we've all been
in the rain together we sweat it
together but it was great to meet people
from all across the country that loved
their country all they showed was love
and they love Fox News and how Sean
Hannity now I will say this Lawrence I'm
gonna tell you something I'm look look
at look at everyone loves Lawrence
Lawrence is a rock star it's
unbelievable a total rock star and well
that showed me so much love look at all
these people right here they don't care
all right do me a favor Lawrence you
tell everyone turn around and say Sean
Hannity says I love them and thank them
for keeping America great Sean Hannity
says he loves you all and thanks for
keeping America group
[Music]
all right I can't believe we pay you to
do this we pay you to do this it's
unbelievable now by the way Lawrence has
the greatest parents job his mom is in
Houston tonight she is a minister of the
gospel of preacher his dad a truck
driver and Lawrence is there we're so
proud of you congratulations on a great
day for you today